المهزع الذي قضايزت فيه الفتره الاطول في
السجن الصحراوي كم كان العدد وكيف كان يتم
التصرف في شخص ستين يعني في
مساحه المهجه 48 متر
فكلنا ستين شخص طبعا بفروع التحقيق يختلف
الامر في فرق التحقيق اثناء فتره التحقيق
يعني في البدايه بيعزلوك بيحطوك بزنزانه
الى ان يمضي فتره من الزمن او يحتاج
زنزانه بيحطوك في غرفه بيسموها جماعيه
فانا عشت مثلا في احدى الجماعيات مساحتها
25 متر مربع كان فيها بلحظه من اللحظات
125 شخص
طيب انتماءات هؤلاء شو كانت مختلف مختلف
مش كله اخوان او
الغالبيه
العظمى كانت هي من التيارات الدينيه بشكل
عام
ولكن يعني
احيانا كانوا يعني ناس لمجرد انه هو صلى
بالجامع حدا بيجيبوه بيحطوه
في الجامع
التهمه الثانيه كان هناك شيوعيين كان هناك
بعثيين يعني العراق كان في
الطريق بالامر انه كان في شيء اسمه رهائن
رهائن هدول
اهالي
المطلوبين
اهالي شخص مطلوب يدك بهم بالسجون
كي يظهر المطلوب حتى يسلم نفسه يعني
واحيانا يتم اعتقال المسجون ولكن لا يتم
الافراج عن الرينه
بعضا من هذه الامثله في الروايه هناك بدات
تتعلم بعض المصطلحات اضافه الى مصطلح
الرهائن المصطلحات الخاصه بالمعتقل ومنها
التسييف ومنها التكبيس ايضا
ما معنى هذين المصطلحين في هاي الغرفه
اللي حكينا عنها مثلا مساحتها 25 متر مربع
وفيها 125 شخص
كان الناس تنقسم ثلاث اقسام
كل قسم بده قسم وقوف
مشان المساحه قسم وقوف قسم
قرفصه او تدوس على الارض ايوه قسم النيام
بالمهجا بين حائطين
رئيس
المهجعوا هذا مشان الناس تنام
فبايهم هيك
راس ورجل راس ورجل
تسييف يعني على جنبه
حتى بيجي اول شخص هيك على جنبه بيجي
الثاني بحط رجل
بيجي الثالث بالعكس هذا بضل يسير يسير في
سيء حتى يمتلئ المسافه بين الحائط هذا
والحائط وبعدين تتبادلون الادوار
بعدين قبل ما نبدل الدوار نفسه من هدول
اللي هذا يكون مسيفين يعني
ملتصقين ببعض ولكن
خلينا نقول فيه الى حد ما رحرحه فهون
بتيجي فيه مع رئيس المهجعه واحد اسمه
الكبيس
بنزل بين اخر واحد والحيط وبيحط رجليه
بظهر اخر واحد وبتفش الجميع بكبسون على
بعضهم
بجيب واحد بنزله برجع بكبس يعني حتى هذا
المساء فيها يعني بين الحيط والحيط حتى
تاخذ اكبر عدد ممكن من الناس هدول الضل
نايمين ثمان ساعات ما بيتحركوا نهائيا
والجالسين على الارض ثمانيه ساعات
والواقفين بضلوا ثمان ساعات واقفين بعد 8
ساعات يتم التبديل اللي كان نايم بروح
بوقف واللي كان واقف بيقعد على الارض
واللي كان قاعد على الارض بروح بنام
بتستمر العمليه هيك ثلاث مرات كل يوم